[Applause]
the pope's welcome was warm but this
visit was about repairing deep wounds
at the site of a former catholic
residential school where for decades
indigenous children were separated from
their parents abused neglected
finally the words canada's indigenous
community has sought for generations
i am here
because the first step of my penitential
pilgrimage among you
is that of again asking forgiveness
of telling you once more
that i am deeply sorry
at least 150 000 indigenous children
were forced into church-run schools in
canada malnutrition was rife children
were physically and sexually abused
the last of these institutions only
closed in the 1990s
and many survivors came to hear the
apology in person
our languages
were suppressed
our culture
taken from us
and our spirituality
denigrated
our spirituality
denigrated
you have heard the devastation that
followed from the way our families were
torn apart
hundreds of unmarked graves have been
found near former homes where children
died at rates several times above the
national average
the pope's apology won't heal their
losses and trauma but it's the
acknowledgment they've long sought that
the church was complicit in their abuse
sally lockwood sky news washington